[Music]
we're volition for you
rated pg-13 get your tickets no they
call it the desktop is capable of
destroying an entire planet if the
Empire has this kind of powerful what
chance do we have the question is what
choices
we have
be with me
rogue one a Star Wars story added pg-13
on your own from the age of 15 reckless
and undisciplined this is a rebellion
isn't it
i repel with a mission for you
we want to help
this is our chance to make a real
difference I couldn't face myself if I
gave up now
I'm not used to people sticking around
when things go back this is the first
for me
rogue one a Star Wars story for the
pg-13 in theaters and IMAX 3d December
16th
vampires building a weapon capable of
destroying an entire planet we have to
capture the plans if there's any hope of
destroying it how will you do it you
make 10 men see like a hundred
welcome to rogue one if the Empire has
this kind of power what chance do we
have
rebellions are built on hope the
Empire's building or terrible weapon I
need your help
she stopped me
this is your chance to make a real
difference
rebellions have built on out
are you with me all the way
just us
Empire's building a weapon capable of
destroying an entire planet they call it
the Death Star need to capture the plans
if there's any hope of destroying it we
want to help all right how many do I
need I'll be there for you the captain
said I had to tell them that we are
dealing with you is immeasurable I will
not sell
the Imperial forces are converging on
our present location
take hold of this moment
the force is strong
tell me you have a back-up plan
punch it
may the force be with us
rogue one a Star Wars story
you almost got me you're welcome radio
pg-13
in theaters December 16th need to find
him all right how many do I need they
are requesting a call sign it some rogue